Remember that the number one way to support
The David Pakman Show is to get yourself a
membership at Join Pakman dot com.
You may not know this because I mentioned
it so infrequently, but we do have a membership
program.
Join Pakman.
Dotcom is the place to sign up.
Let's hear from some folks in the audience
were getting close to the end of the year.
We will soon have a new president.
What is on folks minds?
You can talk to me through our dischord server
David Pakman dotcom slash discord.
Let's go first to Kelsi from Colorado, Kalsi
from Colorado.
You're on the air.
What's going on?
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Awesome.
Well, hey, I'm a big fan of the show.
Thank you.
And watching ever since August.
So it's been keeping me mentally sane.
I love it.
I guess my question is, what do you think
is the end game for the Republican Party as
a whole?
I know they're it seems like they're fragmented.
And I saw the footage of little Lou Dobbs
and Steven Miller kind of figuring out what
what's happening.
And I'm just kind of seeing what is the long
game for them to stay in existence, because
I just don't see it happening with more people
seeming to get involved in younger generations.
Coming up.
What do you think is their endgame?
So you mean you don't mean just their antics
between now and Inauguration Day for Biden?
You mean like really long term for the survival
of the party?
Because honestly, like, they'll keep going.
But I think it seems that more people are
going to get tired of it.
And I feel like it's not sustainable.
So I don't know if they're playing to just
reform or what the deal is.
But what do you think is their endgame?
You know, people have been asking this for
so long and for a long time now, we've been
hearing the Republican Party will eventually
go out of existence because subsequently younger
generations are more and more on the left.
That reversed a little bit because actually
young voters supported Trump at a slightly
higher level than we would have expected relative
to past Republicans in twenty 20 or demographic
changes, including more Latino voters.
Going to some key red states are going to
make those states purple and eventually blue
in the Republican Party won't be sustainable.
So far that's not happened.
Now, part of the reason Kalsi, it hasn't happened
is voter suppression, gerrymandering.
Right.
Figuring out ways other than winning the hearts
and minds of voters to keep winning by preventing
people from voting or whatever the case may
be.
I think that the important takeaway is predictions
of the Republican Party's demise on demographic
grounds have fallen short for decades at this
point.
So we should not assume that they will simply
go out of existence because of the platform.
I believe that they will.
It's not even going to be reform, but they
will just tweak and adjust to continue raising
a lot of money from donors on key wedge issues,
keep suppressing the vote and they are not
going to go away.
What they will look like in 10 or 20 years,
I don't pretend to know.
Gotcha.
Yeah, that makes sense, I feel like there
I that's where my fear is, is that the reforming
is just going to get more and more ensconced
and you're just going have to fight harder
to resist that.
I agree, and in particular now with completely
propaganda based news outlets, everything
from, you know, Breitbart, Gateway Pundit,
Newsmax, 018, which people think are actual
news, it's going to be a big fight.
It's going to be a big fight.
We can't underestimate the importance of that.
So it's a big battle we have ahead of us.
Right.
Well, great.
Thanks for taking my call and talking to me.
All right.
Kelsey from Colorado, very much appreciate
that.
That call.